bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat à suivre cet
après-midi sur notre chaîne un débat
organisé par la commission des affaires
européennes pour préparer le conseil
européen qui doit se tenir à bruxelles
des 14 et 15 mars prochains
il porte notamment sur la coordination
des politiques économiques budgétaires
et de l'emploi les différents états
membres
au moment même où selon toutes les
estimations
la zone euro devrait rester en récession
cette année avec pour conséquence
principale que la plupart des pays
européens auront du mal à réduire leurs
déficits
c'est d'ailleurs le cas de la france
l'engagement du gouvernement de ramener
son déficit à 3% du pib en 2010 7 vient
d'être reportée d'un an après que la
commission européenne l'a jugée
intenable
faute de croissance économique du coup
des négociations sont en cours avec
bruxelles sur le calendrier des efforts
à fournir
car la france est sous surveillance de
la commission européenne qui la
pénaliserait en cas de dérive la
commission peut en effet censuré le
budget d'un état à la dérive mais tout
de suite direction l'hémicycle pour ce
débat préalable au conseil européen des
14 et 15 mars
très bonne après midi à tous sur notre
chaîne l'ordre du jour appelle le débat
préalable au conseil européen des 14 et
15 mars 2013
suite à une demande de la commission des
affaires européennes la parole est à
monsieur bernard cazeneuve ministre
chargé des affaires européennes
ce président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs comme nous en avons pris
l'habitude désormais nous nous
retrouvons à l'occasion de cette séance
pour préparer ensemble les débats qui
auront lieu dans quelques jours au
conseil européen à bruxelles
cette séance doit être pour le
gouvernement l'occasion l'indiqué les
conditions dans laquelle lesquels il
s'apprête à aborder cette discussion
dans un contexte particulier que je veux
rappeler en quelques mots le contexte
est d'abord dominée par la crise que
connaît l'union européenne qui
s'approfondit qui s'aggrave qui pour un
certain nombre de pays s'enkystent avec
une récession qui fait son oeuvre de
destruction d'emplois qui voient le
chômage augmenter partout en europe
le contexte est également celui du
semestre européen c'est à dire de cet
exercice de relations entre la
commission et les gouvernements de
l'union européenne
encadrés par les textes du 6 pack du
tout paquet du traité budgétaire texte
qui permette au gouvernement en lien
avec la commission européenne de définir
les conditions dans lesquelles les
objectifs de déficits publics que les
états se sont assignés à eux mêmes à
l'occasion de l'adoption de leurs
budgets pourront être atteints nous
sommes donc confrontés à un double
exercice celui d'une part d'une
discussion qui doit nous conduire dans
la crise a évalué l'efficience de nos
politiques économiques assurer leur
convergence autour d'un équilibre qui
permettra d'accélérer la sortie de crise
et nous sommes aussi dans un exercice
qui doit permettre de rendre compte pour
les états des conditions dans lesquelles
ils atteignent leurs objectifs de
réduction des déficits
je voudrais rappeler
tout d'abord que la france a souhaité
depuis le mois de juin
s'engager dans une réorientation très
profonde de la politique de l'union
européenne destinée à équilibrer les
politiques de sérieux budgétaire
d'initiatives en faveur de la croissance
lorsque nous sommes arrivés mois de jeu
en situation de responsabilité nous
avions essentiellement trois objectifs
que je veux rappeler faire en sorte que
la croissance redevienne possible au
sein de l'union européenne par des
initiatives prises au niveau de l'union
européenne et permettant d'équilibrer
les objectifs de sérieux budgétaire que
les états s'étaient assignés à eux mêmes
dans le cadre des textes et traités
récemment adoptée au titre du semestre
européen notamment
deuxièmement faire en sorte que nous
puissions pour créer les conditions de
la croissance remettre en ordre la
finance le système financier bancaire au
sein de l'union européenne
troisièmement créer les conditions
notamment dans le réflexe dans le cadre
de la réflexion en cours conduite par
hermann von randow d'un
approfondissement de l'union économique
et monétaire
avec le souci constamment présent à
l'esprit du renforcement de la
solidarité
je voudrais à la veille du conseil
européen sur ces trois sujets essentiels
qui sont ceux autour desquels nous
pouvons construire le rééquilibrage des
politiques de l'union européenne
profitez de notre échange d'aujourd'hui
pour faire un point
tout d'abord les institutions de l'union
européenne comme l'ensemble des pays de
l'union sont bien décidés à faire du
conseil européen de jeudi et vendredi
l'occasion d'un débat approfondi sur la
pertinence des politiques économiques
conduite au sein de l'union européenne
et sur les conditions dans lesquelles
l'équilibré entre croissance et rigueur
budgétaire et solidarité va pouvoir se
matérialiser dans les mois qui viennent
pour ce qui concerne la croissance
le conseil européen a décidé de mettre à
l'ordre du jour de ces débats la
question du pacte de croissance de 120
milliards d'euros
décidé à l'occasion du conseil européen
du mois de juin dernier et dont la
déclinaison sur les territoires est en
cours et dont nous devons profiter de ce
conseil européen pour évaluer très
concrètement l'impact qu'il a sur les
politiques de l'union sur le
développement des territoires et sur la
croissance
ce débat se fera en deux temps il faudra
d'abord une évocation de la mise en
place des instruments du pacte de
croissance par l'ensemble des
institutions de l'union européenne avec
le concours des états de l'union ce sera
l'objet de la discussion de jeudi et
vendredi prochains
puis il y aura une prolongation de ce
débat autour du pacte de 120 milliards à
l'occasion du conseil du mois de juin
qui par-delà l'évaluation de
l'efficacité des instruments izraa
mesurer concrètement les résultats
obtenus par ce pacte en termes de
croissance dans les différents pays de
l'union européenne il arrive très
souvent que à l'assemblée nationale
comme au sénat certains nombres de
sensibilités politiques s'interrogent
avec plus ou moins de bonne foi sur la
réalité de ce plan je veux rappeler que
ce plan se répartit en trois enveloppes
une enveloppe de 55 milliards d'euros de
fonds structurels but c'était dans le
cadre des perspectives financières pour
l'union européenne pour la période 2007
2013 mais non affecté non dépensé une
enveloppe de 60 milliards d'euros de
prêts de la banque européenne
d'investissement du possible à une
recapitalisation de cette banque à
hauteur de dix milliards d'euros et une
première phase ii d'obligations de
projet à hauteur de 4,5 milliards
d'euros rendue possible par la mise en
garantie dans
le budget de l'union européenne de 350
millions d'euros pour ce qui concerne la
france
précisément nous avons sur ses 55
milliards d'euros
une première mobilisation d'une
enveloppe plancher qui ne présage en
rien de ce que sera la mobilisation
globale des fonds au terme de la période
de 2,2 milliards d'euros nous avons le
souhait de faire en sorte que le retour
d'aile près de l'abbaye pour notre pays
soit fortement optimisés pour
l'allemagne le retour des prêts de la
bei d'à peu près 13 % pour la france il
est de l'ordre de 7%
si nous parvenons par une bonne
mobilisation des territoires des
industriels et des services financiers à
optimiser notre retour qui dé près de
l'abbaye
nous pourrions escomptés jusqu'à 7 à 8
milliards de retour en france dès 60
milliards d'euros de prêts rendue
possible par la recapitalisation de la
banque
enfin nous attendons entre 6 et 7 100
milliards d'euros des obligations de
projets ce qui me conduit à vous dire
très précisément je pourrais si ça
intéresse la commission des affaires
européennes vous donner la déclinaison
territoriale de ces fonds et les projets
auxquels ils ont été affectés nous avons
pour la france à peu près 11 milliards
d'euros d'argent européens mobilisés au
titre du plan de croissance dans les
mois qui viennent ce qui par effet de
levier devrait permettre d'avoir un
impact global de ce plan à peu près 24
milliards d'euros ce qui représente dans
le contexte de la crise auxquels notre
pays est confronté
une opportunité à un impact en termes
d'investissements non négligeable je
donne cette précision sur le pacte de
croissance qui sera évoquée à l'occasion
du conseil européen de jeudi et vendredi
qu'il le sera à l'occasion du conseil
européen du mois de juin pour bien
matérialisée devant votre assemblée que
ce plan n'est pas virtuel qu'il a une
transcription concrètes et qu'il est en
train d'être mobilisés et déclinée dans
les différents territoires deuxième
enveloppe dont nous souhaitons qu'elles
contribuent à la croissance celle
enveloppe du budget pour l'union
européenne pour la période 2014 2020
je veux rappeler que pour des raisons
qui tiennent tôt
rabotage constant des crédits de
paiement nécessaire au financement du
précédent cadre budgétaire
il y a eu 260 milliards d'euros du
budget était entre 2007 et 2013 alors
que le budget de l'union européenne
prévoyait une mobilisation crédit
paiement de 942 milliards d'euros c'est
donc 80 milliards d'euros 2 mois que l'
enveloppe de crédits de paiement prévu
qui a été mobilisée dans le cadre du
précédent budget aux termes de la lettre
de novembre 2010 envoyé par l'ancien
président de la république française la
chancelière
le premier ministre finlandais le
premier mystère landais au président de
la commission européenne préconisant
qu'on a beau talent et crédits de
paiement nécessaire au financement des
politiques prévu par le précédent budget
de l'union européenne
si nous mobilisons la totalité des
crédits du budget qui vient d'être
adoptée ces 50 milliards d'euros de plus
que dans le précédent cadres budgétaires
qui seront mobilisés je veux rappeler
que les crédits alloués à la croissance
par le cadre budgétaire que nous venons
d'adopter augmenteront de près de 100 de
40% au cours des six prochaines années
et les budgets du programme connecting
europe de près de 120%
je vais également rappelé que dans le
cadre de ce budget pour ce qui concerne
la politique de cohésion la politique
agricole commune
nous avons atteint tous nos objectifs
nous avons également procédé à la
création du fonds d'accompagnement des
jeunes pour les régions ayant un taux de
chômage supérieur à 25%
tout cela nous conduit à optimiser
fortement notre retour sur tous les
objectifs pour lesquels nous étions
mobilisés dans le cas de la négociation
budgétaire qui vient de s'achever pacte
de 120 milliards budget de l'union
européenne troisièmement nous souhaitons
également que l'approfondissement du
marché intérieur
l'acte 2 du marché intérieur c'est une
très belle occasion pour nous de
multiplier les initiatives de croissance
qu'il s'agisse des efforts que nous
souhaitons que l'union fasse en matière
d'harmonisation sociale et fiscale nous
pourrons parler à l'occasion du
questionnement qui suivra les
interventions qu'il s'agisse aussi de
l'instauration du principe du juste
échange dans le libre échange à travers
les discussions en cours sur les
directives concessions et directives
marchés publics qui permettent de ne
plus ouvrir nos marchés publics à des
entreprises venant de pays qui n'ont pas
ouvert leurs marchés publics à nos
propres entreprises qu'il s'agisse aussi
de la volonté de faire en sorte que le
mieux disant social et environnemental
qui s'applique à nos entreprises avec un
haut niveau de normes élaborées par
l'union européenne ne soit pas un
handicap dans la mondialisation pour les
entreprises de l'union
voilà pour ce qui concerne la croissance
mais nous souhaitons que le conseil
européen de jeudi vendredi qui permettra
de faire un point sur tous ces sujets
qui concernent la stratégie
d'investissements publics la croissance
en europe sera aussi l'occasion de faire
un point sur un autre sujet sur lequel
il n'y aura pas de croissance qu'elle a
remise en ordre de la finance
nous avons réussi depuis le conseil
européen du mois de juin cela a été
confirmé en octobre et en décembre à
créer les conditions sein de l'union
européenne de la mise en place d'une
union bancaire la supervision bancaire a
fait l'objet d'un compromis avec
l'allemagne la commission sous l'égide
du commissaire barnier qui fait un très
bon travail sur ces questions comme sur
d'autres travaillent actuellement à
l'élaboration de textes de nature
législative visant à compléter la
supervision bancaire par un dispositif
de résolution des crises bancaires et de
garantie des dépôts pour que nous ayons
la totalité du dispositif d'union
bancaire dès lors que la supervision
bancaire aura été mise en oeuvre
il sera possible de recapitaliser
directement les banques par le mécanisme
européen de stabilité ce qui signifie
très concrètement que le lien entre
dette souveraine et dette bancaire qui
conduit les états devoir acquitter sur
les marchés financiers des taux
d'intérêt très importants lorsqu'ils
veulent recapitaliser leurs banques
bien ils n'auront plus à le faire et
nous créerons ainsi les conditions de la
possibilité pour le système financier
européen de financer directement
l'économie réelle là où il s'était
laissé aller au financement d'activités
spéculative et destructrice de valeur et
de richesses sur les territoires de
l'union européenne je rappelle que dans
le même temps nous avons acté la
possibilité pour le mécanisme européen
de stabilité le fonds européen de
stabilité financière d'intervenir sur le
marché secondaire des dettes souveraines
la banque centrale européenne a emboîté
le pas à travers le programme out fois
avec mon établissement action qui permet
sur le marché secondaire des dettes
souveraines d'accompagner l'intervention
du ms et du fsl de manière à créer les
conditions d'un véritable pare feu face
à la spéculation
enfin je terminerai par la solidarité
car le conseil européen doit également
être en situation de profil et de
préparer les débats qui auront lieu au
mois de juin sous l'égide du président
du conseil européen herman van rompuy
concernant l'avenir de l'union
économique et monétaire
nous sommes très désireux mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs de faire en
sorte que nous puissions profiter de
cette réflexion conduite par herman van
rompuy pour faire en sorte que sur un
certain nombre de questions nous
puissions approfondir l'union économique
et monétaire et approfondir le
dispositif d'intégration politique qui
sera rendue nécessaire par les progrès
de l'union économique et monétaire
plusieurs options et plusieurs
hypothèses se présentent à nous celle de
l'approfondissement de la gouvernance de
la zone euro car il n'y aura pas de
possibilité pour l'union européenne de
surmonter la crise si elle n'améliore
pas la gouvernance de la zone euro
et si nous parvenons pas à rendre plus
efficient les dispositifs de gouvernance
à 17 en même temps ce que nous serons
pour approfondir l'union économique et
monétaire à 17 ne peut pas se faire au
détriment de l'intégrité de l'europe à
27 il nous faut donc trouver une
articulation entre la volonté que nous
avons d'améliorer la gouvernance de la
zone euro et la volonté que nous avons
de maintenir l'intégrité du marché
intérieur
c'est l'un des enjeux considérables des
débats en cours avec herman van rompuy
avec bien entendu le concours de
l'ensemble des institutions de l'union
était celle des tel gouvernement et nous
devons examiner chacune des opportunités
de cette réflexion la première
opportunité c'est que dès lors qu'il ya
une meilleure gouvernance de la zone
euro de doter la zone euro d'une
capacité budgétaire qui pourrait
permettre à celle ci de faire face aux
chocs de conjoncture et de mener de
véritables politiques de destiné à
surmonter les chocs conjoncturels
lorsqu'ils se présentent à nous de façon
violente deuxièmement et il y a la
possibilité d'approfondir la réflexion
sur la mutualisation de la dette
j'ai souvent entendu dire sur ces bancs
que cette question n'était plus
d'actualité mais les plus européens
d'entre vous auront sans doute remarqué
que le parlement européen a obtenu dans
le cadre du trilogue c'est-à-dire au
terme d'une discussion avec la
commission et le conseil européen qu'un
groupe de travail particulier soit mis
en place
destiné à définir les conditions dans
lesquelles nous pourrions avancer
ensemble vers les eurobéats terne les
robes monde
tout simplement parce qu'une grande
majorité des représentants du parlement
européen toutes tendances politiques
confondues d'ailleurs considère qu'à
partir du moment où il ya une
convergence des politiques budgétaires
autour des disciplines budgétaires
il doit y avoir une possibilité de
mutualiser la dette de manière à faire
en sorte que l'europe dispose de moyens
dont elle ne dispose pas aujourd'hui le
fait qu'au terme du trilogue c'est à
dire d'un échange entre toutes les
institutions de l'union européenne
l'ensemble des institutions de l'union
est acté le principe de la mise en place
de ce groupe de travail témoigne du fait
que nous avons également ce chemin et
cette opportunité devant nous enfin
troisièmement il y a
devant nous la question de l'europe
sociale qui a été mise à l'ordre du jour
des travaux du conseil européen dans le
cadre de l'acte 2 du marché intérieur
de nombreux sujets se présente à nous
qu'il s'agisse de la reconnaissance des
qualifications europe professionnel au
plan européen qu'il s'agisse de la
reconnaissance de la forte habilités des
droits sociaux qu'il s'agisse de la
possibilité d'engager une réflexion sur
la mise en place d'un salaire minimum
européen voilà toutes les questions qui
sont devant nous dans le cadre de la
feuille de route herman van rompuy dont
nous aurons à traiter
au cours des semaines et des mois qui
viennent et puis particulièrement à
l'occasion des deux conseil européen de
printemps de mars et de juin
je voudrais conclure en indiquant que ce
conseil européen sera aussi l'occasion
pour la france d'indiquer la manière
dont elle entend respecter les objectifs
de retracement qu'elle s'est assignée
elle même je voudrais terminer par ce
point les conditions particulièrement
difficiles dans lesquelles évoluent la
conjoncture européenne et notamment la
croissance très faible ne permettent pas
d'atteindre les objectifs de réduction
des déficits que nous nous étions fixés
mais la commission européenne comme la
cour des comptes ont dans leur a promis
valuation de la situation reconnu que
les deux tiers des efforts de
rétablissement du déficit structurel de
la france
résultat des efforts qui ont été
accomplis depuis le mois de juin dernier
ce qui signifie ça va moins mal que
sanaa était en tous les cas monsieur le
président ça va beaucoup moins mal parce
que monsieur le président il faudrait
quand même vous rappelez vous êtes un
homme qui aime les chiffres que la
situation voulait laisser ces 75
milliards de déficit du commerce
extérieur une ba oui mais nous on s'en
souvient parce que ça fait partie des
choses qu'on est obligé de corriger le
doublement de la dette en cinq ans
nakk heureusement absolument abyssale
des déficits ce qui vous autorise avec
beaucoup d'autorité à nous donner
beaucoup de leçons que nous prenons
d'ailleurs avec beaucoup d'humilité
non c'est pas facile c'est la vérité des
chiffres
non mais l'imagination n'est pas
nécessaire quand ces chiffres sont là et
qui nous impose une réalité qui doit
nous interdire toute forme d'imagination
simplement la rigueur des chiffres avec
laquelle monsieur le président réunis
vous avez beaucoup de difficultés ce que
je regrette parce que entre personne
honnête et de bonne compagnie on doit
pouvoir regarder les chiffres avec une
certaine lucidité
je suis désolé de pouvoir ne demandent
rien n'ont absolument les chiffres sont
là vous allez doublé la dette en cinq
ans vous avez laissé un déficit abyssal
et vous avez laissé 75 milliards de
déficit du commerce extérieur ce qui
vous autorise tous les jours à donner de
leçon de sérieux budgétaires et de
compétitivité de l'économie
non je continue pas parce que je pense
que ce que j'ai dit devrait suffire à
vous éclairer et je vais terminer mon
propos et je vais je vais terminer mon
propos en souhaitant que ce débat soit
l'occasion non c'est pas la vérité
officielle c'est la vérité des chiffres
la vérité des chiffres des institutions
françaises auxquelles vous avez souvent
fait référence lorsqu'il s'agissait de
nous accabler mais dense il s'agit de
regarder la réalité en face que vous
avez laissé là les institutions de la
république ne sont plus promptes à
donner les bons chiffres
c'est ce que c'est ce que j'appelle le
contraire de l'honnêteté intellectuelle
et peut-être ai-je tort monsieur marini
et comme je souhaite que le débat seule
occasion de faire la vérité sur tous ces
sujets notamment ce que nous avons sur
ce que nous avons fait que je suis très
impatient de vous entendre la porter la
contradiction j'arrête là mon propos et
je retourne à mon siège avec une grande
une grande envie de vous entendre
développer vos vérités merci monsieur le
ministre
la parole est un monsieur simon sutour
président de la commission des affaires
européennes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le conseil
européen qui va se tenir les 14 et 15
mars prochain est particulièrement
important en effet il va se prononcer
sur les lignes directrices de l'union
européenne concernant les programmes de
stabilité les programmes nationaux de
réforme
vous avez détaillé monsieur le ministre
ce qui est en cause
je remercie donc tout particulièrement
le président du sénat d'avoir veillé à
ce que ce débat se tiennent aujourd'hui
et j'ajouterais dans un horaire
convenable je remercie aussi monsieur le
ministre sa disponibilité pour répondre
à nos questions les récentes prévisions
de la commission européenne confirme
malheureusement la dégradation de la
conjoncture économique
et cela concerne l'ensemble de l'union
européenne selon la commission
européenne la croissance économique ne
devrait atteindre que 0 1% en 2013 dans
l'union dans la seule zone euro
l'économie devrait se contracter de 0 3%
cette faiblesse de l'économie devrait
avoir un impact direct sur le chômage le
taux de chômage devrait atteindre 11,1
pour cent dans l'union européenne et
12,2 pour cent pour ce qui concerne la
seule zone euro avec des pics
extrêmement inquiétant pour le chômage
des jeunes
on ne peut imaginer que cette
conjoncture économique très dégradé ne
sont pas pris en compte dans la
définition des lignes directrices pour
les politiques nationales
l'effort de stabilisation des finances
publiques est en effet une exigence il
doit être poursuivie avec détermination
la france engagée en 2012 et 2013 un
effort d'ajustement structurel sans
précédent mais cet effort doit aussi
s'inscrire dans la durée
selon un calendrier réaliste dès lors
que la conjoncture économique se dégrade
chacun peut comprendre que ce calendrier
doivent être adaptées et il est light le
fmi lui-même a récemment mis en garde
contre l'excès d'austérité c'est la
formule que nous en parlions souvent
le malade tellement guéri qui meurt
guéri il faut aussi poursuivre sur la
voie des réformes structurelles et agir
pour la compétitivité de nos économies
depuis dix mois la france est engagée
dans ce sens nous avons un pacte
national pour la compétitivité et
l'emploi
nous allons bientôt transcrire dans la
loi l'accord historique entre les
partenaires sociaux qui réforme en
profondeur le marché du travail
dans le même temps l'union européenne
doit elle-même mettre au premier plan le
au premier plan le soutien à la
croissance
la france a depuis 10 mois portée ce
débat devant les instances européennes
elle a été entendue avec l'adoption en
juin 2012 du pacte pour la croissance et
l'emploi
il faut poursuivre dans cette voie et
abouti rapidement des réalisations
concrètes
l'emploi des jeunes doit être la
priorité des priorités
en décembre la commission européenne a
proposé un train de mesures dans ce
domaine grâce à la détermination du
président de la république la france
obtenue lors du conseil européen de
février la création d'un fonds de lutte
contre le chômage des jeunes se font de
6 milliard sera destiné aux régions où
le taux de chômage des jeunes dépasse
les 25%
ma région et l as concernés elle va en
bénéficier mais malheureusement je
préférerais que le languedoc-roussillon
ne soit pas concernée je mesure donc à
titre personnel l'importance que peut
avoir dans nos territoires une action
européenne bien orienté intensifier
cette action est d'autant plus
nécessaire que l'europe est facilement
utilisée pour servir de bouc émissaire
aux difficultés nationales
nous constatons tous les jours résultat
des récentes élections italiennes
viennent de nous le rappeler
le rétablissement des finances publiques
ne sera donc compris que s'il
s'accompagne d'une plus grande
solidarité et d'une action énergique
pour la croissance et l'emploi
malheureusement l'épisode de la
négociation du cadre financier
pluriannuel a cruellement révélé
l'altération de l'esprit de solidarité
le budget européen est par définition un
exercice de solidarité
le budget doit aussi réfléter une
certaine vision de l'europe
or nous le savons tous le sens même du
projet européen est aujourd'hui discutée
la phrase doit donc continuer à oeuvrer
comme elle le fait depuis dix mois pour
redonner du sens au projet européen en
le réorientant pour qu'il réponde aux
attentes de nos concitoyens
l'absence de véritables ressources
propres a perverti la négociation les
états membres se sont focalisés sur leur
sol de nettes c'est à dire sur la
différence entre ce qu'ils versent et
ceux qui reçoivent du budget européen
cette logique continuera tant que le
budget sera financé par des
contributions nationales
si la négation même de la solidarité
européenne c'est pourquoi nous devons
travailler à la création de nouvelles
ressources propres
le sénat l'a souligné en décembre
dernier dans ce contexte très difficile
la france a bien négocié quand on se
souvient de la manière dont les
discussions s'étaient engagées nous
avons réussi à éviter le pire
de plus nous ne sommes qu'à la première
étape du processus
je voudrais insister là dessus
le parlement européen dispose d'un réel
pouvoir puisqu'il doit maintenant donner
son approbation à ce budget européen qui
résulte d'un accord du conseil
nous souhaitons je souhaite qu'ils le
mettent à profit pour revoir à la hausse
certaines enveloppes
ce serait la preuve que l'esprit de
solidarité encore un sens en europe
puisque l'on va fixer des lignes
directrices sur les politiques
nationales nous devons aussi nous
interroger sur leurs cody coordination
d'un côté nous avons des pays qui ont
des excédents une compétitivité élevé de
l'autre se trouve des états qui luttent
pour réduire leurs déficits que les
premiers relance leur demande intérieure
serait bénéfique pour l'ensemble de
l'union européenne
c'est aussi cela la solidarité
européenne
notre débat se déroule alors que se
développent les réflexions sur
l'approfondissement de l'union
économique et monétaire
le conseil européen a adopté une feuille
de route en décembre celui de juin
prendra des décisions
il est indispensable que ces décisions
concilie la rigueur financière avec une
approche dynamique en faveur de la
croissance et de l'emploi
j'insiste
toujours sur ces mots croissance et
emploi pour cela il faut aller vers plus
d'intégration à partir d'objectifs
partagés
nous travaillons à rendre nos économies
plus forte et plus compétitive mais nous
avons aussi besoin d'une harmonisation
des politiques fiscales et d'action
ambitieux au niveau européen pour
développer les infrastructures et
encourager la recherche
c'est pour cela que nous avions insisté
dans notre résolution de décembre 2012
sur l'importance du projet de mécanisme
européenne interconnexions dans ses
trois volets transports énergie et
numérique
dans ces conditions la diminution
envisagée par le conseil européen de 50
à 30 milliards des moyens consacrés à ce
mécanisme de l'interconnexion est
particulièrement préoccupante
nous sommes aussi inquiets des moyens
qui seront alloués au programme horizon
2020 en matière de recherche
et là on peut s'interroger où est le
souci de croissance enfin une europe
réorienter une europe réorienter c'est
une europe qui a une véritable ambition
sociale face à la situation de l'emploi
la solidarité doit s'exercer à l'égard
des territoires durement touchée par le
chômage
c'est l'intérêt du fonds de lutte contre
le chômage des jeunes dont la france a
obtenu la création c'est aussi l'enjeu
du fonds d'adaptation à la
mondialisation ou du fonds d aide
alimentaire qui à la demande du
président de la république sera
maintenue à un niveau de 2,5 milliards
d'euros
et là je voudrais quand même interrogés
parce que c'est vraiment inquiétant car
nous avons ce type de débat au niveau
européen de voir certains pays qui
remettent en cause ce type de mécanisme
lié aussi avantage a lancé nous l'avons
souvent dit mais nous le répétons
aujourd'hui des emprunts communs entre
états membres
nous aurions alors l'expression de cette
solidarité cette solidarité concrète que
l'europe doit traduire aujourd'hui si
elle veut éviter
et ça c'est très important c'est le défi
majeur de l'avenir si elle veut éviter
la désinfection des peuples je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à michel andré vice présidente de la
commission des finances monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
françois marc retenu par des conditions
météo un peu difficile
enfin département aurait dû s'adresser à
vous je vais tenter de vous intéresser
quelques minutes sur ce question cette
question pourquoi ne nous intéressons
nous pas plus finalement à l'europe et
donc j'espère nous pouvons jour par jour
le moyen d'en faire un peu plus de
l'apprécier davantage et peut-être de se
considérer dedans et pas comme c'est
souvent le cas à côté et critique
monsieur le président le ministre mes
chers collègues ce débat préalable au
conseil européen des 14 et 15 mars
souligne la volonté du parlement en
avoir toute sa place dans ce qu'il
convient désormais d'appeler le semestre
européen
en effet la prochaine réunion du conseil
va traiter de questions importantes
vous l'avez évoqué monsieur le ministre
est mon cher collègue simon sutour
relatives à la trajectoire économique et
budgétaire des pays européens dont celle
de la france dans ses recommandations
adressées à la france en juin 2012 le
conseil européen avait rappelé
l'objectif de ramener notre déficit
public à 3% en 2013
faut-il encore rappeler qu'au moment de
ces recommandations la commission
européenne estimé la croissance du pib à
1,3 pour cent pour l'année 2013 cet
objectif on le sait ne sera pas atteint
en raison de la dégradation de la
situation économique dans l'ensemble de
la zone euro
à cet égard certains semblent tentés de
verser dans le catastrophisme mais cela
n'a pas beaucoup de sens vouloir coûte
que coûte ramener le déficit public à 3
% en 2013 sans considérer le contexte
économique provoquerait une récession
qui nuirait en retour à notre
trajectoire de redressement
la cour des comptes ne recommande
d'ailleurs pas de prendre des mesures
supplémentaires de 2013 pour atteindre
l'objectif des 3% mais insiste sur la
réalisation effective de l'effort
structurel programme et notre
crédibilité repose sur notre
détermination à redresser durablement
nos finances publiques
pour la première fois en 2012 les
dépenses de l'état ont été inférieures à
celles de 2011
s'agissant de l'année 2013 l'effort
budgétaire est jugé sans précédent par
la cour des comptes elle-même
enfin entre 2010 et 2013 selon la
commission européenne la réduction de
notre déficit structurel ce sera établie
à plus de 4 points de pib comme la
france s'y était engagé
cette détermination ne peut donc être
mise en doute et justifie que nous
obtenions de nos partenaires européens
le report à 2014 de l'objectif de retour
du déficit sous les 3%
il faut d'ailleurs rappeler qu'en juin
2012 le conseil n'avait pas fait
référence au tsc g qui résonne
uniquement en termes de solde structurel
car il n'était pas encore entré en
vigueur
toutefois les institutions
communautaires devront prendre en compte
cette évolution de la gouvernance de la
zone euro qui si elle ne modifie pas le
pacte de stabilité aura nécessairement
un impact sur la manière dont elles
décideront de l'appliquer
s'agissant des prévisions de déficit
public pour 2013 et 2014
personne pas même la commission
européenne n'est capable de dire
aujourd'hui avec certitude ce que seront
la croissance du pib et l'évolution de
nos recettes en fonction de celle-ci
mais elle montre l'effort supplémentaire
que nous pourrions avoir à produire en
2014 pour faire en sorte que notre
déficit public soit sensiblement
inférieur à 3% du pib
cet approfondissement de l'effort le
gouvernement l'a engagé c'est le sens
des audits qu'il a demandé dans le cadre
de la modernisation de l'action publique
et de la réflexion initiée en vue d'une
nouvelle réforme des retraites
ce sont ces réformes qui permettront de
sécuriser durablement notre redressement
et qui sont attendus par nos partenaires
européens comme d'ailleurs par les
investisseurs plutôt que des mesures qui
permettraient d'atteindre les 3 % de
2013 sans considération de leurs
conséquences immédiates et futures
le gouvernement a pris des mesures
importantes pour relancer la croissance
et dynamiser le marché du travail
le pacte national pour la croissance la
compétitivité et l'emploi doit permettre
aux entreprises d'embaucher d'investir
et de gagner des parts de marché dans ce
cadre le crédit d'impôt pour la
compétitivité et l'emploi opérer un
déplacement significatif de la fiscalité
du travail vers la tva et la fiscalité
écologique qui doit favoriser notre
transition énergétique
au delà de ce pacte l'accord national
interprofessionnel conclu en janvier
dernier dans la transcription dans la
loi nous sera soumise prochainement
devrait permettre de dynamiser notre
marché du travail
ces mesures visent à renouer avec une
croissance durable et améliorer notre
compétitivité
elles ne sont certainement pas en
contradiction avec les recommandations
adressées à la france par le conseil
européen en juin 2012 qui rejoignent
d'ailleurs celles qui nous sont faites
par plusieurs organisations
internationales et observateurs
étrangers
il s'agit donc de convaincre pleinement
ceux de nos partenaires européens qui
resteraient à lettres de notre
détermination à redresser nos finances
publiques et à renouer avec une
croissance plus forte afin d'obtenir le
report d'une année de l'objectif de
retour sur les 3% de déficit public
il faut aussi invité le conseil européen
a préconisé des orientations favorisant
le retour de la croissance et l'eau et
l'amélioration de la situation de
l'emploi dans l'ensemble de l'union
européenne
car c'est dans la faible croissance que
réside la cause de nos déficits
au delà de la part structurelle que tous
les pays européens s'emploie désormais à
résorber
je vous remercie
j'indique au sénat que la conférence des
présidents a décidé d'attribuer un temps
de parole de huit minutes au
porte-parole de chaque groupe politique
et de cinq minutes à la réunion des
sénateurs ne figurant sur la liste
d'aucun groupe
le gouvernement répondra ensuite aux
commissions et aux orateurs dans la
suite du débat
la parole est aux orateurs de groupe et
je passe la parole à monsieur ronan
dantec pour le groupe écologie
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues sans
ignorer
nous en avons parlé l'importance du
premier point au programme du conseil
européen de cette semaine je centrerait
mon propos sur le second items figurant
au projet d'ordre du jour qui porte sur
les relations extérieures de l'union
ils sont en effet l'occasion de procéder
je cite un échange de vues ouvert sur
les relations avec des partenaires
stratégiques étant entendu que le
conseil européen ne devrait pas adopté
de conclusions écrites sur ce sujet
cette formulation n'a rien d'original
elle est même assez habituel pour les
conseils européens
cependant le contexte actuel n'est pas
anodin en particulier s'agissant des
partenaires stratégiques de l'europe
entendu ici principalement au sens
économique
je fais le lien avec l'annoncé faite
récemment par le président obama sur le
lancement prochain de négociations
visant à instaurer un accord de libre
échange qui engloberait les deux rives
de l'océan atlantique union européenne
et etats-unis
ce serait le plus important accord de ce
type jamais conclu dans le monde
il concernerait le tiers du commerce
international la moitié de la production
économique globale autant dire que son
rôle de régulation et son impact sur
l'économie mondiale serait centrale il
est certes de coutume d'évoquer ces
sujets dans le cadre de discussions sur
les questions commerciales autant
silence plus que durant un point sur les
affaires extérieures
mais il paraît difficile de ne pas
prêter une dimension stratégique globale
à ce nouveau partenariat éventuel avec
des états unis et que savons nous à
cette heure du dialogue qui s'ouvre
d'abord qu'il devrait débuter
formellement cet été en effet c'est le
conseil du mois de juin qui devrait
donner à la commission européenne le
mandat par lequel elle mènera les
négociations
d'où aussi l'intérêt des discussions
informelles qui s'amorce maintenant
ensuite si l'on en croit les précédents
et notamment la recherche d'un accord du
même type avec le canada nous pouvons
craindre que ce dialogue ne brille pas
non plus tout à fait par sa transparence
et enfin les sujets abordés ne sont sont
loin aujourd'hui d'être consensuel en
l'occurrence cet accord de libre échange
ne devrait pas diminuer drastiquement
les droits de douane sont déjà faibles
on parle de taux moyen situé aux ans
autour de 3 5% pour les importations
depuis l'europe vers les états unis et
de 5,2 pour cent en sens inverse
on peut toutefois remarquer qu en les
restreignant encore on affirme qu'il ira
d'autant c'était l'intervention
précédent le budget de l'union des
droites de doha déjà presque marc
gillaux suite à d'autres accords
similaires on représente environ 15%
aujourd'hui il faudra quand même voir
comment compenser cette diminution
si vous nous voulons donner toujours une
certaine ambition au budget européen et
à sa capacité d'agir sur l'économie
européenne mais c'est dans le domaine de
la réglementation sanitaire sociale ou
environnementale que cet accord pourrait
avoir le plus d'impact et ses
conséquences pourraient bien s'avérer
négative pour les citoyens et les
consommateurs européens les états unis à
l'europe nous le savons ont une
conception de la protection des données
personnelles qui diffère radicalement ce
qui pose déjà des problèmes avec des
gens comme google ou facebook
la presse en ait beaucoup fait l'écho
ces derniers temps dont le modèle
économique repose justement sur la
commercialisation de ces données ça sera
une question complexe
les états unis et l'europe ont aussi une
vision totalement différente des modes
de production alimentaire et du principe
de précaution la politique agricole
commune est déjà sur un certain nombre
de points problématiques mais on parle
ici de la possible importation d'auge m
de volaille traitée au chlore ou de porc
soigner à de fortes doses
d'antibiotiques les élus et le lobby
agroalimentaire américain ont d'ores et
déjà écrit à l'administration obama pour
réclamer que ces points précis soit
compris dans les négociations or ce
serait évidemment pour nous une
évolution totalement inacceptable dont
l'éventuelle et main l'éventualité même
paraît absurde aujourd'hui alors que
nous trouvons au milieu de ce scandale
sanitaire à l'ampleur non négligeable
vous trouverez sur ce point et je tenais
le dire cet après midi vous trouverez
sur ce point l'échelle européenne des
écologistes particulièrement attentifs
et mobilisés pour la défense de
l'environnement et la santé des
consommateurs
au vu de ces enjeux le débat se devra
donc d'être transparent et d'associer
les instances législatives et la société
civile
les écologistes ne sont pas opposés à
priori à l'idée d'accords commerciaux
mais cette idée ne doit pas conduire un
nivellement par le bas de règles dont le
seul but est de protéger la santé la vie
privée ou le bien-être des européens les
rapprochements entre législation sont
évidemment possibles
toutefois un accord avec des états unis
aussi étendue ne serait pertinent que
dans la mesure où il instaurerait un
terrain d'entente minimale qui serait
déjà un mieux disant par rapport aux
pratiques actuelles en vigueur dans le
monde sur toutes ces questions mais
aussi encore plus globalement je
conclurai là dessus sur les questions
climatiques ou de préservation de
ressources
il serait alors bien plus aisé
d'affluence et ses dernières contenu du
poids coréen tel marché par rapport aux
autres acteurs économiques s'est
véritablement dans ce cadre que nous
devons appréhender
l'ouverture de ces négociations après
les annonces de l'administration obama
sur la nécessité de répondre au défi du
changement climatique
engagement confirmé par la nomination de
john kerry avec en perspective la fin du
cycle de négociations climatiques
entamée et à d'urban il ya maintenant un
peu plus de darrigand et qu'ils finiront
à paris en 2015 nous devons plus que
jamais liée négociations commerciales et
climatiques pour un accord de régulation
globale vital pour l'avenir de nos
sociétés
l'expérience que nous pouvons avoir de
l'échec des précédentes négociations
climatiques vient justement de
l'incapacité que nous avons eue c'était
tout particulièrement le cas à
copenhague a lié ce qui concernait le
commercial et ce qui concerne l
environnement à partir du moment où ces
grandes négociations s'ignorent elles
sont condamnées à l'échec
cette fois ci le calendrier de
l'administration obama est cohérent ou
tout du moins compatibles avec ces
échéances c'est une chance que nous ne
devons pas laisser passer
le volontarisme européen sur le climat
ne doit pas être limitée au discours de
façade
il doit s'insérer dans une logique
cohérente de toute la diplomatie
européenne
les négociations commerciales
bilatérales en font partie que ce soit
avec des états unis mais aussi
évidemment avec la chine et des grands
pays émergents
car soyons lucides l'aggravation des
crises environnementales qui se
déclineront derrière en crise
alimentaire et sociales conduira sans
nul doute au repli
et à la fin du libre échange ceux qui
pensent donc que les échanges
économiques mondiales et globalement
bénéfique doivent donc intégré urgemment
dans leurs propres logiciels les enjeux
environnementaux
s'ils ne veulent pas demain assisté
impuissant aux replis nationaux dans un
monde en souffrance
merci chers collègues la parole est un
monsieur philippe marini pour le groupe
ump
sur le ministre mes chers collègues en
ce début d'année
il me semble que jamais la distance
entre l'europe institutionnelle et nos
concitoyens n'a été aussi grande
jamais la distance entre eux les propos
officiels techniques technocratique que
l'on nous tiens et la réalité des choses
telle qu'elle est vécue jamais sans
doute cette distance n'a été aussi
considérable
c'est ainsi que je sens les choses et je
crois que cette distance est à l'image
de celle qui sépare deux langages le
langage que notre pays a dans les
enceintes feutré des réunions
ministérielles ou institutionnels à
bruxelles ou ailleurs avec ses
partenaires et le langage que le même
gouvernement a vis-à-vis de l'opinion
publique et des divers représentants des
milieux qui composent notre société et
nous avons bien vu une expression de
cette distance entre les opinions et
l'europe institutionnelle avec les
élections italienne c'est bien une
réalité
il faut tenir compte de la réalité telle
qu'elle s'exprime par le suffrage et
sans doute aussi avons nous affaire à
des instances européennes qui est bien
souvent font semblant font semblant pour
avancer font semblant pour et laisser
croire qu'il y a
consensus ou une direction commune alors
que bien des choses reposent sur l'à peu
près où sûr
le malentendu ainsi en va-t-il de la
coordination des politiques fiscales
quand on lit les documents officiels
il est question de progresser en matière
de fiscalité de l'énergie de fiscalité
de l'épargné ou encore vers une assiette
commune consolidée de l'impôt sur les
sociétés mais qu'en est-il de la réalité
chacun le sait aucune chance n'existe de
faire progresser ses sujets à brève
échéance
car tout dépend de la vie d'un seul des
27 et vous même monsieur le ministre
lors d'un précédent débat lorsque je
vous ai interrogé sur le renflouement
financier de chypre vous n'avez pas eu
une seule parole à propos de l'impôt sur
les sociétés au taux de 10%
vous m'avez répondu bien entendu comme
tout à l'heure en incriminant le
gouvernement précédent et en incriminant
le précédent président de la république
à propos des affaires irlandaise d'alors
mais au moins mais au moins le président
de la république d'alors avait-il
dénoncé le dumping fiscal de l'europe
même s'il n'a pas été rejoint par ses
partenaires
alors qu'aujourd'hui sur les 10% de taux
d'impôt sur les sociétés applicable à
chypre
je n'ai pas entendu l'ombre d'une seule
parole
si je puis ainsi m'exprimer au moins mes
chers collègues en ce début d'après midi
j'ai suscité votre attention
ce qui sur un sujet européen n'est pas
nécessairement chose facile il est
encore plus gênant d'observer les
ambiguïtés en matière bancaire
on ne sait plus vraiment quel est le but
politique recherchée à travers l'union
bancaire on nous dit qu'il faut rompre
le lien entre dette souveraine et dette
bancaire
mais aucun n'accord vous le savez
monsieur le ministre sur les conditions
dans lesquelles le mécanisme européen de
stabilité pourra prêter directement aux
banques
ne semble se dessiner vous en avez parlé
pourtant c'est une figure de style une
figure convenu mais il n'y a aucun
calendrier
il n'y a aucun progrès réels en ce sens
et vous le savez fort bien
alors peut-être est-il nécessaire de
tâches et de rendre un sens politique à
ce que nous faisons dans le cadre de
cette construction européenne
sans doute est il nécessaire que les
parlements nationaux utilisent mieux
l'article 13 du tsc j'ai alors que
jusqu'ici les rencontres qui se sont
multipliées demeure désespérément
formelle sans doute est il nécessaire de
mieux s'approprier ce qui nécessite du
travail mes chers collègues dans le
débat national
les notions les procédures les
instruments qui nous parviennent à
partir du droit communautaire et en
particulier qui nous parviennent de ce
tupac qui vient d'être finalement adopté
mais encore faudrait-il que nous
sachions est exactement comment
s'enchaînent les notions des contrats de
croissance et de solidarité aux plans
budgétaires nationaux en passant par
bien d'autres choses et l'ambiguïté dans
laquelle nous sommes sans doute existe
t'elle aussi entre eux les
recommandations adressées par le conseil
européen à la france en matière de
réformes structurelles et la manière
dont notre gouvernement de façon
erratique souvent contradictoires à mon
sens décline sa politique et les
chantiers à ouvrir en matière de
compétitivité de réforme du marché du
travail de fiscalité écologique de tv un
de formation professionnelle de salle
hermine
mom tout cela me semble au minimum
marqué du sceau de l'ambiguïté entre le
langage européens que nous recevons que
nous acceptons et le langage nationale
que nous pratiquons or mes chers
collègues et je terminerai par là notre
pays même s'il semble abandonnée dans
l'immédiat
l'objectif de déficit nominal de 3 % du
produit intérieur brut en 2013 a le
devoir de demeurer crédible et nous le
savons le gouvernement l'a indiqué lors
du conseil des ministres du 27 février
il semble exclu il est considéré comme
inopportun de prendre cette année des
mesures supplémentaires des mesures
supplémentaires de gestion budgétaire
au-delà de celles qui sont déjà mises en
oeuvre mais alors monsieur le ministre
que répondre à ton si autour de la table
du conseil
on nous demande si nous serons capables
de rester sans rien faire
lorsqu il s'avérera que le déficit
probable de 2013 s'approche des 4%
que répondre at on lorsqu'on nous
demandera s'il est crédible de conserver
comme objectifs pour 2014 pour la fin de
2014 un déficit compris entre 2,5 et 3 %
alors que les prévisions
macroéconomiques de la commission comme
des meilleurs experts nous indique que
sans mesures supplémentaires de
consolidation budgétaire nous risquons
de nous trouver plutôt près de 4% et
enfin en tout état de cause pour 2014
nous le savons puisqu'il n'est pas prévu
de semble-t-il de faire d'effort
supplémentaire en 2013
compte tenu de l'ensemble des facteurs à
prendre en compte il faudrait que les
mesures supplémentaires représentent
c'est un ordre de grandeur
entre 20 et 40 milliards d'euros ce qui
représente 1 à 2 points de produit
intérieur brut efforts gigantesques en
effet effort qui à ce stade n'étant pas
documenté précisé ne semble pas
réellement crédible ce qui semble-t-il
est de nature à porter atteinte au
crédit de notre pays
mes chers collègues c'est au moment où
le conseil européen va examiner les
grandes orientations de politique
économique
ce conseil européen de printemps que ces
questions se posent et pardonnez moi
monsieur le ministre de de voir les
poser même si elle vous semble
désagréable merci de votre attention
merci chers comme ailleurs la parole est
à monsieur michel ville ou pour le
groupe crc
c'est le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
les hospices sous lesquelles se prépare
ce conseil européen cette semaine sont
bien sombres
les nuages s'accumulent partout en
espagne au portugal en grèce en bulgarie
en italie et même dans notre pays les
conséquences d orientation européenne
voulue et défendue par les gouvernements
montrent les limites de leur efficacité
économique et ont surtout des
conséquences dramatiques pour les
peuples
la croissance c'est partout en berne et
les prévisions pour cette année ne sont
guère optimistes
les chiffres du chômage explosent
n'avons nous pas ce trimestre dépasser
dans notre pays la barre symbolique de
10% de chômeurs indemnisés sans compter
celles et ceux qui n'ont pas droit aux
allocations et qui de fait
n'apparaissent pas dans les statistiques
cette politique d'austérité voulues
orchestré par l'union européenne et des
états qui la composent mène à l'impasse
partout elle provoque des crises
sociales économiques et politiques le
pacte budgétaire d'octobre dernier que
nous avons refusé de valider dans notre
groupe portait en lui les germes de ces
drames sociaux que nous vivons au sein
de l'union
le volet croissance de cet accord qui
devait nous apporter un mieux économique
et social n'a pas résisté longtemps aux
dogmes libéraux qui sous tendait le
traité l'austérité est bien pour
maintenant la croissance elle pour plus
tard peut-être monsieur le ministre vous
allez pendant deux jours échanger avec
vos collègues sur la coordination des
politiques dans le domaine économique
budgétaire et de l'emploi ainsi que sur
les orientations des programmes de
stabilité et de convergence
beau programme s'il en est mais si l'on
traduit la novlangue européenne cela
veut dire accord sur la logique de
récession et d'austérité
celle ci nous le voyons bien a aussi des
conséquences sur le code du travail
l'accord a aisni sur la sécurisation de
l'emploi en france est bien de la même
ces recettes seront elles aussi le fil
conducteur de la future réforme des
retraites et des allocations familiales
je vous pose la question les mêmes
recettes n'ont elles pas déjà été
appliquée en espagne en italie en grèce
après l'avoir été en allemagne même avec
quels résultats
le patron de renault expliqué récemment
qu'ils ne comprenaient pas pourquoi
l'accord de compétitivité dans son
entreprise en france n'étaient pas
acceptées par tous alors qu'en espagne
il avait obtenu l'accord des salariés
mais croyez-vous que lorsqu'on a le
couteau sous la gorge
on est en mesure de négocier d'égal à
égal
mais cette crise n'est d'ailleurs pas un
moment difficile à passer pour tout le
monde
il y à cette année 200 milliardaires de
plus dans le monde est la première
fortune française de madame bettencourt
s'est encore accru cette année
que doit-on en penser que l'europe qui à
répu qui aurait dû jouer ce rôle de
bouclier social
cet exemple mondial de mieux disant
social a décidé au contraire de
s'aligner sur le moins disant social
dans ces conditions la course vers une
meilleure compétitivité de l'économie
européenne face aux économies des pays
émergents et de la puissance étasunienne
risque bien d'être perdue d'avancé
c'est exactement le comble un verre ce
qu'il faut faire c'est par la relance du
marché intérieur européen que l'on peut
espérer un nouvel élan de l'économie et
la relance passe par une politique
d'investissements tant européens que
nationaux mais aussi par une politique
salariale volontariste qui permettrait
aux européens de reprendre le chemin de
la consommation donc de la croissance et
de l'emploi
est ce dire qu'il ne faut pas
s'intéresser aux modes de production et
eau chaude produite non bien entendu
l'europe reste un espace où la recherche
et l'inventivité sont encore une réalité
mais pour combien de temps à chaque fois
que l'on ferme un laboratoire ont fait
rotules et notre capacité d'innover et
donc de réussir
or il nous faut absolument développer la
recherche
car la relance de l'économie européenne
ne peut que passer par le respect des
critères de développement durable et du
progrès social
vous allez engager la discussion après
demain sur les orientations européennes
pour sept ans l'accord sur le budget
européen que vous avez négocié en
février et que vous avez qualifié de bon
compromis a été rejetée par la
quasi-totalité des groupes au parlement
européen
pervenche berès présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales au
parlement européen a ainsi toute autre
lecture que la vôtre monsieur le
ministre à l'annoncé au cours d'une
récente réunion à bobigny avec des élus
et des acteurs départementaux de la
solidarité qu'elle s'opposerait à sa
ratification en l'état par le parlement
que doit-on en penser cet accord est en
fait la consécration des égoïsmes de
certains états
croyez-vous sincèrement alors que
l'europe s'enfonce dans la crise qu'il
fallait réduire d'un milliard d'euros
les budgets de solidarité élargir le
nombre de pays éligibles alors que le
nombre de bénéficiaires de ces aides ne
cesse de croître partout en europe
c'est pourtant le message que la france
que l'europe envoie aux 25 ans cent de
la population de l'union qui vit en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté
la confédération européenne des
syndicats ne s'y est pas trompé pour la
première fois celle ci a demandé aux
parlementaires européens nationaux de ne
pas ratifier un traité européen
croyez vous que cela soit une nouvelle
lubie de la gauche de la gauche non la
confédération confirme dans son appel à
manifester à bruxelles que l'europe
n'est pas une zone de libre échange mais
un espace dont l'objectif est le progrès
économique et social
et elle poursuit dans sa déclaration une
feuille de route sur la dimension
sociale de l'union dans le cadre d'une
coordination renforcée des politiques
doit tendre à une convergence ascendante
pour s'attaquer aux inégalités à la
pauvreté au chômage et au travail
précaire qui sont éthiquement
inacceptable et créer une situation
d'urgence sociale
voilà quel devrait être votre feuille de
route monsieur muni dans cette
négociation
vous ne seriez pas isolé vous vous
seriez le soutien du monde du travail
des exclus des précaires
des forces vives européenne si en
revanche l'union européenne poursuit le
même chemin elle contribuera à créer de
la désespérance et de fait à renforcer
les nationalismes lazer nos phobies et
les égoïsmes les résultats des élections
en italie devrait nous faire réfléchir
bien sûr le chemin est étroit et
difficile mais pensez que la france
n'est jamais aussi grande que
lorsqu'elle tient le discours de la
justice que de l'égalité
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à madame catherine morin
desailly pour le groupe u10 uc
projet
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes très chers collègues voilà
plusieurs mois que j'ai le plaisir de
participer aux travaux de notre
commission des affaires européennes
je dois dire que je me réjouis de la
qualité générale de nos débats et des
propositions stimulante des collègues
qui ensuite a bien un diagnostic juste
dans sur le fonctionnement d'union que
sur les actes législatifs qui sont
produits voilà pourquoi on ne peut que
regretter que le débat préalable au
conseil européen soit finalement un
exercice un peu stérile de commentaire
pourtant toujours intéressant sur un
ordre du jour qui nous dépasse et nous
interpelle quoi qu'on en dise par sa
vacuité politique
je regrette à vrai dire le caractère
essentiellement tribunicien rester au
parlement en l'absence d'une procédure
qui nous permettrait sur le modèle de
l'article 88-4 de la constitution de
peser davantage sur le conseil européen
l'ordre du jour du prochain conseil
appelle la conclusion de la première
phase du semestre européen consacré à
l'examen des efforts de coordination
entrepris par les états membres en
matière de politique budgétaire en soit
on ne peut que se satisfaire de la
montée en puissance du principe de
coordination qui reste l'un des grands
acquis du pacte pour l'euro adopté il ya
deux ans et pourtant monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je ne peux
que mesurée l'insuffisance de notre
exercice et de la réunion du conseil
face à la crise et au ressentiment que
traverse qui traverse
pardonnez moi aujourd'hui l'europe les
dernières élections d'italie ont été
l'occasion de la sanction dramatique du
gouvernement de mario monti mis à mal
par la progression spectaculaire de
formation populiste
ce phénomène est identique dans beaucoup
de pays membres la récente déclaration
de david cameron relatives à une
éventuelle sortie de la grande-bretagne
de l'union par la voie d'un référendum
attise aussi les tensions populiste que
l'on retrouve par ailleurs en france
n'oublions pas que les formations
eurosceptiques et populistes ont cumulé
près de 30% des suffrages exprimés
au même moment le parlement français
notamment le sénat notre assemblée a été
privé d'un véritable débat et d'une
véritable explication sur
le budget européen ce débat pourtant
demandé conjointement par jean louis
borloo à l'assemblée et françois
zocchetto ici même sur les modalités
consternante d'adoption d'un budget qui
ne peut que nous sidéré à plusieurs
égards ce budget engagera la prochaine
commission et le prochain parlement
à moins d'un an des prochaines élections
européennes
comment ne pas pointer une telle
anomalie institutionnels budget
concernant enfin puisqu'il est pour la
première fois en nette diminution et
pourrait remettre en cause à terme les
investissements d'avenir investissement
dont nous avons terriblement besoin pour
démontrer à nos concitoyens que l'europe
n'est pas un carcan que l'europe n'est
pas un poids mais qu'elle est au
contraire une force d'avenir une force
pour l'emploi une force pour la
formation l'éducation et l'avenir de nos
enfants
le groupe u10 et avait demandé à
plusieurs reprises
un débat spécifique sur cette question
mais à chaque fois on nous renvoie au
débat préalable sans plus de précision
comme si l'europe finalement n'avait
qu'une place restreinte au parlement
ainsi nos discussions masse mal le fossé
qui se creuse sans cesse entre l'union
les citoyens et l'idéal européen que
nous devrions tous partagé l'europe de
la manière dont elle fonctionne ne
correspond plus aux aspirations de la
population
peut-être at-on mal mesuré d'ailleurs
les racines profondes du référendum du
29 mai 2005
à certains égards le non à la
constitution a été le signe
avant-coureur de la crise morale que
traverse le continent aujourd'hui les
générations actuelles n'ont pas connu la
guerre
aussi nous nous nous ne pouvons plus
uniquement invoquer le souvenir des
pères fondateurs de l'europe comme
l'argument d'autorité suprême dans le
débat européen
l'europe ne peut plus vivre seulement
comme un idéal alors que nos concitoyens
nous demande une europe concrète une re
protectrice une europe de la prospérité
une robe de l'emploi bref une robe de
l'avenir et pas seulement une robe
mémorielle qu'ils se reposeraient sur
les lauriers du travail déjà accompli
le groupe u10 et se veut le porte parole
de la voix européenne dans le débat
public national et c'est justement parce
que nous sommes viscéralement attaché à
l'idée européenne que nous nous
permettons
critique à l'égard du fonctionnement
actuel de l'union
j'ai eu l'occasion dans le cadre de ma
mission sur l'europe du numérique de
travailler avec l'administration
bruxelloise et force est de constater je
suis désolé de dire que nous faisons
face à une administration d'un autre
temps l'europe doit redevenir une
aventure politique tournée vers l'avenir
et ne saurait rester une machine
purement technocratique leurs sentiments
de nos concitoyens est désormais trop
palpable la crise est trop grave
vous l'avez d'ailleurs appelé monsieur
le ministre pour que nous en restions à
tel degré de complexité d'éloignement
entre l'union et le peuple
ce ressentiment doit nous alerter sur la
marche à suivre
désormais et il nous faut impérativement
resserrer le lien entre l'union et les
citoyens au regard du prochain conseil
européen
nous mesurons tous que le tsg donnera de
fait à la commission un pouvoir
considérable en matière budgétaire et
donc en matière fiscale
or nous ne pouvons pas oublier en tant
que parlementaire que la première des
responsabilités des assemblées et de
garantir le respect du principe du
consentement à l'impôt et de voter le
budget
comment voulez vous assurez le lien
démocratique entre l'union et les
citoyens si la commission décide de tout
sans être responsable de rien comment
cela pourrait-il vive lorsque les
décisions entrer dans le destin de
millions de citoyens européens se joue
parfois dans des cénacles refermer entre
2h et 3h du matin prenons un exemple
précis la rectification des prévisions
de croissance de la france pour cette
année impose au gouvernement pour se
conformer aux exigences de sa
programmation prise en conformité avec
les stipulations du tsc g de souscrire à
deux hypothèses pour maintenir une
trajectoire vertueuse de désendettement
soit vous jouez sur les recettes et vous
serez contraint de créer de nouveaux
impôts pour combler l'écart de
prévisions soit vous jouez sur
l'exécution pour imposer des économies
aux administrations de l'état dans tous
les cas la simple correction d'un chief
par bruxelles entraîne des conséquences
lourdes pour nos concitoyens et remet
une fille née en cause l'autorisation
votée en loi de finances initiale
c'est la démocratie parlementaire
nationale qui est atteinte par le manque
de démocratie au niveau fédéral
nous nous devons donc associer les
citoyens à la prise de décision
politique pour faire de l'europe une
europe politique
nous devons renforcer les pouvoirs de
contrôle des parlements nationaux
nous devons enfin établir une véritable
définition du principe de subsidiarité
pour enfin sauter le pas deux noms à
l'union des compétences véritablement
fédéral et en contrepartie d'une
démocratie renforcée qui rendra l'union
politique et stratégique et non plus
administrative et technocratique et les
états s'occuperont de ce qui est leur
ressort naturel je ne peux plus compter
le nombre de fois où je suis interpellé
comme vous l'êtes d'ailleurs vous aussi
par exemple les entreprises qui souffre
d'une concurrence déloyale imposé de
fait par bruxelles à travers un ensemble
colossal de normes qui finalement
favorise naturellement les entreprises
étrangères
petroplus dans mon département en est un
exemple mais combien d'autres encore en
france
monsieur le ministre comme vous le savez
le groupe fuji c est le groupe politique
ou l'engagement européen est unanime et
semble naturellement aller de soi c'est
au nom de cet engagement que je partage
avec mes collègues que je souhaiterais
que vous nous éclaire y est non pas tant
sur la position de la france dans la
procédure de conclusion du semestre
européen mais sur les propositions du
gouvernement en matière de restauration
du lien de confiance entre l'europe et
ses citoyens
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à jean claude requier pour
le groupe
rds
monsieur le président monsieur mise mes
chers collègues avant d'aborder les
enjeux de ce conseil européen de
printemps constitue une étape importante
d'une ourse semestre européen
j'aimerais revenir un instant sur le
compromis budgétaire issus du dernier
conseil européen de février
ce n'est pas évidemment le résultat de
nous rêvions malgré les défend la france
pour préserver les politiques
traditionnels le nouveau cadre financier
pour la période 2014 2020 représente une
réduction des crédits de l'ordre de 35
milliards d'euros par rapport à
précédente et de 12 milliards par
rapport à propositions de herman von
rompuy formulée en novembre
j'entends bien que ce compromis est le
moins mauvais possible dans le contexte
européen le plus difficile que nous
ayons dû affronter et face à des pays
conservateurs majoritaires au conseil
qui entendait procéder à des coupes
partout j'ai le sentiment aussi qu'aux
intérêts nationaux ont été dans une
large mesure préserver ainsi si les clés
de la pac ont diminué les retours
français sont maintenus ce résultat est
très satisfaisant n'était pas gagné la
france
je salue à offin les avancées non
négligeables obtenus concernant la
jeunesse
que ce soit les crédits du programme
erasmus ou les initiatives pour l'emploi
des jeunes voulue par le président
république est doté de 6 milliards
d'euros le chômage frappe à l'effet
durement les jeunes plus d'un sur deux
en grèce à l'espagne et d'âge les
régions de l'italie et du portugal
l'union européenne est parvenue à sauver
ses banques à me dépassant 7,5 milliards
d'euros mais peine à dégager les
milliards d'oat indispensable pour
soutenir directement les catégories
victimes la crise
cela étant nous avons des doutes quant à
la capacité de ce budget à relancer la
croissance et à renforcer la
compétitivité de l'économie européenne
car c'est bien de cela qu'il s'agit
aujourd'hui
quoi qu'il en soit cette proposition de
cadre financier pluriannuel doit encore
être approuvé par le parlement
européen ce ne sera pas facile si on en
croit les déclarations des responsables
des principaux groupes politiques qui
ont tous dénoncé un budget d'austérité
dans un tel contexte le moins qu'on
puisse attendre du conseil européen qui
se montre ouvert jamie de la volonté de
négocier affichée par le parlement
européen de la position est positive et
constructive sur plusieurs points
importants je passe notamment à
proximité entre rubrique ou à la
nécessité d'envisager de nouvelles
ressources propres
comment progression se fait derrière
questions notamment la taxation des
transactions financières que nous
appelons de nos voeux et dans le
principe a été décidé au fond le
principal intérêt du conseil européen à
venir sera de nous en dire plus sera
portée politique réelle de l'ensemble
des réformes de la gouvernance
économique entreprises ces dernières
années la crise a rappelé la très forte
interdépendance des pays européens est
donc l'utilité d'une approche à la fois
large et coordonnée des choix
économiques et sociaux nationaux sur ce
sujet quels sont les progrès aujourd'hui
le projet européen semble se limiter à
une gestion disciplinaire des politiques
budgétaires et à quelques
recommandations économiques sans grande
incidence concrète
oui il est indispensable de réduire les
dificits pour autant cette stratégie
pour d'autres étaient mineures avec
discernement
d'ailleurs lé ocde où les familles qui
ont pourtant pressé pendant de longues
années une discipline budgétaire absolue
comme seule et unique voie de rédemption
nous aimer aujourd'hui à sortir de
l'austérité
les gouvernements et les peuples qui ont
entrepris des ajustements à la fois
nécessaire et douloureux ne peuvent se
faire sans cesse rappelée à l'ordre par
la commission
sinon à considérer celle ci comme une
maison de redressement budgétaire
il semble que celles ci soient disposés
à une certaine flexibilité à l'égard de
plusieurs pays dont la france pouvait
nous ne confirmé monsieur le ministre
la plupart des pays de l'union
européenne sont actuellement confrontés
à des perspectives de récession
voire de dépression selon les prévisions
de la commission
treize d'entre eux auront un déficit
excessif c'est à dire supérieurs à 3% du
pib en 2013
la consolidation des comptes publics est
certes nécessaire mais ce qui compte
c'est avant tout les orientations prises
par l'équivalent de l'union et moi le
calendrier qui doit être réaménagée
chaque fois que nécessaire les
difficultés que notre pays traverse
actuellement sont essentiellement liées
à la conjoncture comme le prouvent nos
bons résultats à maintient le déficit
structurel
la cour des comptes a d'ailleurs
souligné dans son dernier rapport
car réalisant un effort structurel de 1
40 point en 2012
notre pays a non seulement respecter ses
engagements
ce qu'a reconnu la collision mais
également réalisé un effort jamais
réalisé depuis plusieurs décennies
le cos et européenne doit évoquer l'état
d'avancement du pacte pour la croissance
et l'emploi notamment en ce qui concerne
le marché unique
quelles sont les principales priorités
il faut maintenant ramener le volet
financier de ce pacte c'est à dire
confirmé la mobilisation des 60
milliards de fonds structurels non
utilisés
l'augmentation des capacités de prêt de
la banque européenne d'investissement et
lancement de projets ce bonus c'est
encore plus nécessaire qu'il y un an
compte tenu de l'évolution de la
croissance et de la nature du compromis
sur le budget communautaire qui vient
d'être conclue par le conseil européen
en fait l'europe a besoin d'intégration
politique et surtout d'une dimension
sociale pour une authentique union
économique et monétaire
cette réflexion est assez entamée sur
les l'impulsion de la france dans le
contexte actuel avec un taux de chômage
qui ne cesse de battre des records de
mois à mois au sein de l'union et plus
encore au sénat zone euro et tous les
indicateurs qui vire au rouge
provost t précarité énergétique qu'il
faut rééquilibrer la proche privilégiées
jusque là avait la crise le projet
politique de l'europe ne peut pas se
limiter à sauver des banques il nouvelle
tournée vers la postérité la création de
richesse
l'innovation la formation l'emploi et
surtout la france
quelle est la voie sur laquelle le
gouvernement peut assurer de l'homme qui
soutiendra du coup de gauche qui plaide
pour une europe plus forte plus
démocratique et plus solidaire en
matière d'europe
arrêtons les normes les interdits et
l'omniprésence des réglementations
redonne du souffle du corps et de la
hauteur s'étaient déliées tour va venir
messieurs les miss parle-nous d'europe
et essayer de nous faire un peu rêver
merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur alain richard
pour le groupe socialiste
le pays d'enhaut sionisme chers
collègues mes premiers mots sont tout
simplement pour remercier le
gouvernement de nous proposer le
président sutour a bien fait de rappeler
le rôle aussi du de notre conférence des
présidents pour organiser ce débat à
bonne date et en remerciant aussi
gouvernants le ministre pour sa capacité
dialogue toujours très développée avec
le parlement on sent qu'ils apprécient
les échanges parlementaires et il le
pratique avec beaucoup de talent leur
exprimer au nom du groupe
une tentative d' approche de politique
générale sur le point nous en sommes sur
les dossiers du conseil européen et de
politique générale d'abord européenne
l'a bien senti chez au moins un des
orateurs précédents la tentation assez
visible de détourner le débat vers des
questions de politique intérieure qui
n'ont pas forcément tourner à son
avantage d'ailleurs mais il me semble
que la perspective doit être celle de
l'union européenne et de ce que nous
sommes capables collectivement d'enfer
il me semble que l'état de situation
qu'on peut décrire et que nous nous
approchons de la sortie de crise
financière et j'essaye de justifier cela
sur les deux points la gestion des
finances publiques de nos 27 pays et la
gestion de notre système bancaire commun
le nouveau dispositif de préparation
concertée des budgets et des comptes
nationaux se met au point commencent à
se roder le dialogue avec le parlement
européen gagne en profondeur et il faut
je crois encourager jeu nous comptons
sur vous monsieur le ministre comptant
sur gouvernement pour encourager la
commission à jouer pleinement le rôle
d'un dialogue ouvert et tenant compte
des impératifs économiques des
impératifs de croissance avec le
parlement européen dans la préparation
de ses perspectives budgétaires
les dialogues avec les parlements
nationaux doivent aussi s'approfondir
pour que toutes les opinions
démocratique qu'il relatives à la
politique financière de nos pays
mais la politique aussi
collective que nous menons plus
s'exprimer y compris celles qui
continuent à défendre l'intérêt de
d'accumuler de nouveaux déficits
je crois qu'il vaut mieux que la
persuasion et lieu que la valeur
relative des différentes opinions
puissent être testés et donc je crois
qu'il faut considérer comme bienvenue
le développement de ce système
maintenant acquis qui est fondée sur des
décisions définitives et à un moment
simplement dans nos démocraties le fait
majoritaire reprend ses droits et une
fois que les opinions et le dialogue
avec les institutions européennes s'est
développée et bien c'est au gouvernement
et à la majorité qui le soutient de
prendre leurs responsabilités sur les
options budgétaires qui seront prises
mais en cohérence et c'est un point sur
lequel il m'arrive d'assister en étant
un petit peu déplacé en réalisant un
climat de confiance entre états
européens et entre autorités budgétaires
rappelons nous quand même que si nous en
sommes là et je réponds d'un mot à
madame morin desailly sur ce point là
qui mettait en cause les technocrates
si les technocrates sont obligés de
vérifier les comptes
ma chère collègue budgétaire apportées
par les différents états c'est parce que
la situation désastreuse
nous nous sommes trouvés il y a trois
ans était le résultat de falsification
de comptes
il faut bien ressortir et je n'assiste
pas plus sur ce coin là
enfin chacun est obligé de balayer
devant sa porte je pense aussi que le
dialogue parlement européen parlements
nationaux doit encore être approfondies
parce que dans une union monétaire
la solidarité financière qui se fait
progressivement doit se faire dans la
clarté vis-à-vis des citoyens et donc
nous allons continuer d'ailleurs tout
prochainement entre parlementaires
français à discuter sur la bonne
application de la résolution dite
ancrage démocratique pour savoir comment
nous pouvons encore progresser et
surtout comment nous pouvons explicité
vis-à-vis de nos mandants vis-à-vis de
notre pinho démocratique
les choix
budgétaire que nous faisons en ayant
dialoguer entre européens ce qui me
semble être un progrès tout simplement
je crois que les les avancées qui ont
été réalisées sur ce point permettent de
constater que la consolidation
collective des finances publiques des 27
est en bonne voie
et comme le disait un orateur précédent
il avait tout à fait raison
c'est dans cette président d'ailleurs ce
président surtout c'est le point
d'avancer vers la mutualisation de la
dette
si on a créé les conditions de la
confiance si on a mis ses comptes au
clair dans des conditions transparentes
vis-à-vis des partenaires les objections
qui avait un peu de fondement c'est ça
le crédit au sens étymologique du terme
est-ce qu'on ait cru eh bien ces
conditions ce s'éclairciront et nous
pourrons aller vers une véritable
solidarité budgétaire
l'autre aspect qu elle faisait allusion
de la sortie de crise financière c'est
la mise en place l'année est vraiment
décisive à 2013 dans la régulation
bancaire partagé qui était il faut
reconnaître une énorme lacune du
dispositif de leur hôtel que il avait
été mis en place une douzaine d'années
et qui est indispensable pour prévenir
de nouveaux dérapages bancaire de
nouveaux dérapages financiers comme ceux
qu'on a connus au cours des trois ou
quatre dernières années
crois que les engagements sur la
supervision sont réglés en principe mais
si vous en avez le loisir nationaliste
rendu répondant je pense qu'il est
important que vous nous disiez le degré
de dire l'optimisme que vous avez sur
l'accomplissement de l'ensemble des
formalités maintenant des procédures de
mise en place du dispositif d'ici à la
fin de l'année ce qui est un objectif
politique que je crois nous partageons
et qui répond à un besoin de sécurité
des marchés des acteurs financiers et en
particulier je crois que cette
sécurisation du système financier
conjoint des 27 sera une grande étape là
aussi pour notre stabilisation
financière c'est un manque de l'union
européenne et il faut se le dire avec
lucidité que nous avons négligé les
gouvernements successifs et les
majorités successives pendant toute la
période calme qu'on a été obligés de
traiter en ambiance de crise mais nous
sommes en train d'en sortir il faut
saluer ce résultat on pourra noter au
passage d'ailleurs rang tiré peut-être
quelques réflexions que dans la
négociation un accord préliminaire s'est
constitué largement majoritaire pour
resterait un plafonnement des
rémunérations dans le système bancaire
européen et que ceux ci a été l'occasion
de constater une situation un peu
particulière de négociation de nos amis
du royaume uni lesquels devraient me
semble-t-il
et je lis vraiment un également qui
s'appelle beaucoup s'interrogeaient sur
les conséquences qu'elle pour leur
propre économie totalement récession
prolongée depuis deux ans et demi de
l'hypertrophie du système financier
totalement dérégulé et aussi sur leur
capacité l'entraînement et de deux ans
dire de conviction de parcs de partage
d'opinions au sein du conseil de l'union
européenne depuis la position prise par
le premier ministre cameron consistant à
dire qu'il mettait en doute la poursuite
de la participation du royaume-uni à
l'union européenne et donc c'est un plan
c un plan sciences power deux parties si
nous avons su organiser dans la douleur
une sortie de crise financière nous ne
trouvons pas encore collectivement la
sortie de la crise économique
manifestée par le déficit de croissance
certes il ya des contrastes entre pays
et d'ailleurs même si on regardait plus
finement entre régions à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne
certains secteurs et certaines certaines
régions géographiques s'en sortent mieux
que d'autres
la tendance globale est quand même à une
stagnation prononcer le président du
tour a cité les bons chiffres tout à
l'heure 0 1% de croissance anticipé pour
2013 et plus de 11 % de chômage en fin
d'année de ce fait le débat
vous en avez déjà eu beaucoup monsieur
le ministre mais on peut poursuivre les
change doit être poursuivies et
approfondies sur les modalités sur le
rythme du rééquilibrage des finances
publiques et le maintien d'une demande
suffisante car ces mondes se rappeler
que en tant que grands ensembles
économiques comme comme les états unis
l'union européenne est une économie
collective en relativement peu ouverte
les échanges extérieurs de l'union
européenne comptent pour moins de 15% de
son pin collectif et donc la demande
interne et quand même le premier moteur
de la croissance dans un ensemble comme
celui là donc est-ce que le dispositif
de retour vers les équilibres financiers
n'est pas trop brutale des troupes
indifférenciée c'est une question à mon
avis sur laquelle il faut poursuivre le
débat nous partirons de trois points
solide pour poursuivre ce débat me
semble-t-il un ça a été dit par
plusieurs orateurs nous avons fait une
grande partie de notre travail
d'assainissement budgétaire 2 la
commission dans son rôle d' expertise
l'a reconnu de façon inconditionnelle 3
beaucoup de voix en europe et de toutes
tendances politiques s'expriment pour
souligner le risque de la stagnation
donc le débat va se poursuivre
l'argumentaire du gouvernement
à notre avis est convaincant pour aller
plus vite dans le sens de la croissance
nous le partageons
je ne reviens pas sur l'application du
papier croissance que vous avez
mentionné monsieur mais sinon pour vous
poser une autre question puisque vous
étiez très très engagé pour que la
mobilisation de ces ressources de ses
capacités d'investissement portent sur
des buts des projets en france je sais
que vous faites prenais beaucoup de
contacts dans ce sens là donc si vous
pouvez nous aider à nous dire comment
vous progressez ce sera utile d'un mot
de conclusion
l'enjeu de tout cela est profondément
politique et je pense d'ailleurs que
l'orateur de l'ump l'a relevé à sa façon
certes avec des approximations mais le
point je voudrais lui répondre s'il
était encore parmi nous c'est que ce qui
est d'abord politique
c'est la majorité de la commission
européenne majorité conservatrice et la
majorité du conseil européen qui l'est
tout autant
donc ceux qui aujourd'hui ont des
reproches à faire à l'état la
construction européenne ue
à la perception par les peuples comme il
a dit de l'union européenne devrait se
poser la question de savoir si sa propre
famille politique est largement dominant
dans les institutions